the league of extraordinary gentlemen is
going to get another quack at the whip
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
movie channel
[Music]
here i am about to go to work when i
read the news that the league
extraordinary gentleman is about to have
a tv series made by 20th century's
pictures um for the hulu network
i'm a little bit embarrassed i was
actually told this about a week ago and
i forgot to tell you because of all the
things that were happening at mgm et
cetera et cetera but
but yeah it's been confirmed today it's
out there and lots and lots of sources
here i stand for all to see
there's some parlor game believe it
easy now alan
i'm feeling a bit of a draft in my
nether regions
and i must say
it's quite refreshing
so the leader of sony gentlemen into a
tv series this is something that seems
to be happening quite a lot at the
moment uh netflix is about to release
resident evil we've obviously had
westworld over the last couple of years
but yeah projects that a few years ago
would have gone become maybe a movie
franchise and now more and more often
becoming a new streaming service
franchise
and to be honest for a project like the
league of extraordinary gentlemen i
don't think it's a bad thing
um this was quite a successful comic
book and back in the day um very violent
very very very you know serious comic
book um and lots of big characters lots
of big character development something
that's quite difficult to do in a movie
a two-hour movie is decent character
development so in this respect a
streaming service 10 episodes which is
what i've been told is probably going to
be commissioned is not a bad thing
transportation is forthcoming
a
boat it travels on water if that's what
you mean
and
beneath it
[Music]
i've also been told this will not fall
into the trap of the movie now the movie
2003 that ended sean connery's career
not really but he retired just after
fell into the trap of being a pg-13
it also fell into the trap of possibly
taking itself a little bit too seriously
and not embracing the silliness and
that's something i i talk about with you
guys quite a lot in these videos is that
projects like this
are
have to walk a very fine line between
the extraordinary and the ridiculous
something marvel particularly in the
early movies was really good at is just
staying within the extraordinary and not
going over into the silly husband was
jonathan harker
together with a professor named ben
helsing we fought a dangerous evil
it had a name
dracula he was transylvanian hmm
european
one of those radicals and newspapers
love to report on
i don't know mr skinner
is the vampiric sucking of people's
blood radical behavior so that is
another trap that this movie this series
must not fall into and i'm told isn't
going to so the two things i'm being
told is that one it will be a series for
adults not for children it will not have
a 12a or a pg-13 sort of rating it will
be a proper comic book series for
grown-ups
the other thing i'm being told is that
it will at times embrace the silly it
knows the bits of this series that are
maybe a little bit ridiculous and will
make fun with that
because if you don't know much about
lakeshore and gentlemen i have to say
it's it's basically around
imagine victorian london but jules verne
bram stoker all of these great novels
from that time and great science fiction
from the time was actually true
so jekyll and hyde is running around and
the invisible man is running around
dracula is running around
um all of these things like um the
nautilus and twenty thousand leagues
under the sea and so and so on are true
now this it really does allow for sort
of an amazing piece of
a visual spectacular series if you if
they really do it right but also could
be
silly the other thing about the comics
was they were incredibly violent
as with all good comic books at the time
i'm thinking like spawn and
comics like that
incredibly violent that didn't transfer
to the movie very well again it's
another reason why spawn failed
so if they do embrace that and i'm told
they're going to this will be a very
grown up variable very violent series
then i think this is something that
could be amazing it will look amazing
and
it should have a really good character
development and
depth of story because there's lots and
lots of material here for them to work
off
something else that i remember about the
2003 movie another reason probably why
it failed was the style of it not just
the fpg 13 the special effects and
things had a certain style
another film that had the same style
van helsing
you're a big one
you'll be hard to digest
i'd hate to be such a nuisance
um van helsing with um hugh jackman was
2004 the year after a league of story
gentlemen if you look at both films back
to back the special effects of things
are very very similar but also the style
of the film is very very similar
now i'm not saying that rick should um
now i'm not saying it's because of
rickshaw no i can't say the words i'm
not saying that because of richard
rooksboro who happened to be in both he
played moriarty and lead the
extraordinary gentleman who played
dracula in van helsing now i'm not
saying he's to blame
but you know you were on both films mate
so um
but yeah these there seemed to be a bit
of a phase
around this early 2000s of films like
this this style like this and they
weren't very good
but um hopefully this new project will
learn from those mistakes and we'll do
something that over 18s will enjoy
um that's visually spectacular which i
think it will be they've got lots of
material to work from but with very
interesting twisty storylines because
that's the one thing with this comic
book as well they really did have twisty
stories he never quite knew who the bad
guy was who the good guy was even the
good guys they you know the actual
league they had very dubious reasons
they weren't very altruistic they
weren't like good guys for the sake of
being good guys they were good guys for
other reasons guilt and things like this
i'm thinking about lady dracula you know
she was guilty about her past and so she
was trying to
wipe some of the blood from her ledger
as it were
so yeah let's see what they do with this
i'm really looking forward to it if you
are new to the channel guys please like
subscribe hit the bell notification as
always
consider becoming a sidetracker it
really helps me out and i try to get
these things out to you as quickly as i
possibly can
um
and as always guys please stay safe
i better get to work
[Music]
you